Je t'attends, mon père vient de mourir alors
tu es venu sur la route sinon pourquoi
serais-je ici il est parti très
soudainement beaucoup de choses ont changé depuis que tu étais ici cet
enfer OST comment vas
-tu
marié c'était nous trois ouais il est
parti c'est nous deux il est toujours en
colère contre moi
tu as disparu
où t'es-tu marié Asti j'ai senti
que le mariage me guérirait pourquoi pas avec
notre meilleur ami tu n'es pas marié tu
dois trouver  quelqu'un qui est comme ça
devrait être
est-ce comme ça devrait être ou est-ce
juste une obligation appropriée Je pense juste
à ta vie à New York J'ai suivi le
décalage horaire Je savais quand tu étais
réveillé
moi vous avez toujours
été honnêtes l'un l'autre
Effie elle profite de vous
[Musique]
tu devrais le manger
je suis né dans cette communauté je n'avais pas le
choix qu'est ce que tu vas faire
il n'y a rien de plus tendre que d'être libre
de choisir
[Musique]
vous